what bearing does faith have on the
lives of people in today's world world
shaped by the processes of globalization
now we can talk about faith as
represented by faith traditions but
always faith is carried on by
individuals and individuals that are in
particular way challenged by this
question our political leaders how shall
shall they bring their own faith
perspectives to bear upon their own
public life are the risks involved in
being identified as persons of faith can
they in some way craft and shape
ethically based politics that is shaped
by the way in which they themselves
believe what are the compromises in
which they maybe have to be engaged as
they do so in order to take into account
the complex realities of the world in
which they find themselves what are the
means of resolving conflicts between the
claims of the faith and the demands of
the concrete situation in which they
find themselves the issue is really
complicated even more if we think that
in many places in the world
globalization processes are increasingly
bringing people of various religious
persuasions and some who do not believe
at all into a common space now it's not
just a matter of asking the question how
individual faith is brought to bear in
public life but how is it brought to
bear in the pluralistic settings where
different people have different visions
comprehensive visions of common life and
moral life in general and they vie and
want to insert themselves in their own
perspectives into common life these are
issues on which the health and
prosperity and stability and peace of
our common world depend and politicians
often are at the heart of those issues
especially those who them
elves are persons of faith